Vsauce Kevin here let's get inspired by
dairy eye hair sideburns there's
evidence of humans making cheese dating
back 7,500 years dairy herding goes back
9000 it's believed our ancestors were
lactose intolerant so they ate fermented
foods like yogurt and cheese which turn
lactose into lactic acid and it was also
easier to transport the protein-rich
cheese curd than milk the idea that
eating carrots improves eyesight is a
myth originating from World War two the
British developed a new radar system to
shoot down German planes at night but
they wanted to keep it a secret so they
created propaganda citing an excess of
eating carrots by their pilots as their
reason for success carrots do have beta
carotene which converts to vitamin A a
lack of which could lead to health
problems but any well-rounded diet will
supply enough vitamin A people started
wearing powdered wigs because of
syphilis there was an epidemic in Europe
and patchy hair loss was one of the
symptoms so the wigs were needed to
cover up the rampant baldness the powder
was scented with orange and lavender to
cover the odor of the accompanying sores
and rashes soon after king louis xiv and
king charles ii wore them to cover their
thinning hair and they started a trend
that spread throughout the aristocracy
with the term bigwig coming from those
who could afford the biggest most
elaborate wigs having facial hair on the
side of the face has been around since
at least 100 BC and we know this thanks
to a mosaic featuring Alexander the
Great sporting the style but the name
sideburns comes from a u.s. Civil War
General Ambrose Burnside he had facial
hair across the cheeks that connected to
his mustache and it became known as
Burnside's sideburns came into style a
few years later by shaving the moustache
leaving you with just the burns on the
side now if we take out the air like
this
the ey-s and burns what we're left with
is die and hide an easter egg tradition
humans have been decorating eggs for
millennia with engraved ostrich eggs
discovered in Africa going back sixty
thousand years christians of mesopotamia
stained eggs red in tribute to the blood
of christ and the egg itself represents
the resurrection of the lord but modern
adults ranked red as the least popular
color with their favorite being blue and
as always thanks for watching
you